well a remarkable story crossing today
cnn of all places reporting that the
biden administration will use
private groups to spy on american
citizens
without a warrant quote outsourcing some
information gathering to outside firms
would give the department of homeland
security
the benefit of tactics it isn't legally
able to do
in-house because the constitution such
as
using false personas to gain access to
private groups used by suspected
extremists end quote
extremists being of course a euphemism
for anyone who didn't vote for joe biden
meaning you
josh hawley has thought a lot about big
tech and its uses and misuses he's the
author of the new book the tyranny of
big tech it's out from regnary this week
his contract with simon schuster having
been canceled
for no obvious reason senator hawley
joins us tonight senator thanks so much
if there was ever a story that
underscores
your concern it puts it into bright
relief it's this
going around the constitution due
process or the protections that we have
of our civil liberties by using big tech
against us
yeah that's exactly right tucker thanks
for having me on this is a great example
of how the government big government run
by the left is partnering up with big
tech to try to trample on the first
amendment and that's the whole point
here
of course the left can't use government
directly to spy on americans without a
warrant although i will just point out
they did lie repeatedly to the fisa
court during
the donald trump administration to try
and get warrants
wiretaps on trump on others or at least
on trump associates
and told all kinds of lies the fbi did
but they're not now they're going beyond
that why even bother with the pfizer
court when you can get
big tech to actually do the spying for
you and report back to the government i
mean this is why
these companies should not be allowed to
have the power that they do
and at the end of the day tucker this is
why we need to break them up
so the question of who's going to be
targeted who's the new al qaeda who are
the american citizens who are going to
be treated like terrorists it's got to
be a real one for you
so you cast a vote that many others in
your position at the end of presidential
election cycles have cast
okay there's precedent for the vote that
you cast but because you cast it
and because you were such a prominent
critic of big tech and if in a corporate
america to some extent
you were targeted for destruction and
described as an extremist you lost your
book contract from simon schuster and a
lot else
under these standards why wouldn't you
be targeted
as oh i'm sure i'm sure i would be and
i'm sure i have been i mean i i have
i assume tucker every day that google
and apple and facebook and twitter and
all the rest monitor everything that i
do online to the extent that they can
just like i'm sure they do to millions
of other americans and this is the sad
state that we've reached in this country
that if you disagree with these woke
corporations and with their partners in
government on the left
then you will be monitored you will be
tracked they already take all of our
information our personal information all
americans
they do that without asking us and then
they sell that information without our
consent
and now they're trying to use it for
political purposes this is what happens
when you have massive monopolies that
then partner
with leftists and government and again
this is why we've got to break up these
companies and break up this big tech
big government alliance amen because
surely there's nothing you can do about
it
they can lie to you they can steal your
information spy on you at the behest of
the body administration nothing you can
do
i agree with that senator in godspeed in
your quest to break them up
thank you thank you hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else